[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome to 8.20.
Welcome to Special Relativity.
And let me start by
wishing you all a happy New
Year, happy New Year 2021.
I'm pretty sure
this is going to be
an exciting year with
a lot of changes ahead
and a lot of exciting events.
My name is Markus Klute, and I
will guide you through this IAP
lecture on special relativity.
This is very likely my
favorite class at MIT, A,
because it's IAP, and
we start a new year.
There's a lot of
excitement in the air.
And we have a chance to focus
for this one month of January
on this specific subject.
B. I have a chance to introduce
a man, Albert Einstein,
through a discussion
of his physics,
through discussion
of him as a person,
and also through a discussion
of the historic context
in which he developed
special relativity.
And C, if this is
the first time you
encountered special relativity,
it will blow your mind.
And it actually is quite
fun as an instructor
to do a little bit
of a transformation
in your understanding
on physics.
So let's get started with a
quote, with an Einstein quote.
I have a number of those
as we go through the class.
This one here is really kind
of the theme of the class.
Let me just read this to you.
"It is not the result
of scientific research
that ennobles humans and
enriches their nature,
but the struggle to
understand while performing
creative and open-minded
intellectual work."
It is really the struggle with
the ideas, really the trying
to get understanding which
ennobles humans and enriches
their natures.
And let me add here that,
through your own work,
through your own mind,
you can transform
yourself and your understanding
of physics in general.
This first video and
this first lecture
will mostly be concerned
with organizational topics.
So I'll lay out the
schedule of the class
and also how you get a
grade, of what kind of PSETs
we have in mind and so on.
Let's get started.
So I introduced myself
already-- again, Markus Klute.
You can reach me by email.
It's klute@mit.edu.
We have a graduate TA, Justin.
His email is given on
the slide, as well.
And then we have,
too, graders and TAs--
Mohit.
Zach, YuQing, and Stephen.
Those four will guide us
through the class, as well.
And especially when we
go into breakout rooms
in the live class, they will
help you in the discussion.
The class hours are from
3:00 to 4:30 PM on Zoom.
And you can-- I encourage
you to join the class,
to participate, to be
active in the class.
But you will also be able
to get through the material
through recordings.
I will not record
the live class,
because I want to encourage you
to be just as open as possible.
But I pre-record the class, and
after the class time is over,
I'll upload those videos
for your reference.
And also, if you live in
a different time zone,
you have a chance to
listen to the class.
Office hours will be Tuesday at
9:00 AM and Friday at 5:00 PM.
Tuesday, you reach me, and
Friday you reach Justin.
Will set up a Slack
workspace which
we use for our
internal discussions
with a teaching staff.
But there's also
going to be channels
for you to discuss
PSETs as channels
we discussed for physics.
And there's going to
be a channel, which
will be important when we
go to the exam discussion.
The expectation is that you
spend about 30 hours a week
during IAP.
Some will find the PSETs
very straightforward
and quickly to do.
Others will need more time.
So not a-- don't set your
stopwatch for 30 hours.
That's just an average guide.
I will evaluate you at
the end of the term,
and I will use this metric here.
50% of your grade will
come from the homework.
There's going to be five
different homework assignments.
There's going to be two
midterms with 15% each and one
final that's 20%.
If I do the math correctly,
this should lead us to 100%.
You earn an A with 90%, a
B with 75%, a C with 60%
or higher, a D
with 50% or higher,
and then a failing grade
with less than 50%.
So all lectures will be on Zoom.
You'll find the Zoom
links on the Canvas page.
And you probably
found this already.
Otherwise, you wouldn't be
able to find this video.
And again, as I was
saying, the recordings
will be available after class.
This is the schedule.
Let me start by
explaining this picture.
That's Little Thomas here
and then a German ICE train.
This class-- the way
I look at this class
is that it's a
train which is just
leaving the station right now.
And it will very
slowly pick up pace.
But you want to make sure
that you stay on the train
and you don't jump off, because
this will, once it's picked up
its pace, will be a
fast moving train.
And missing a few
days in IAP will
cause you to have
trouble following
along with the material.
We'll start today with
this introduction.
Tomorrow, we have a
very interesting lecture
by David Kaiser.
This is the only one where we
actually record the live event.
So we record the Zoom session.
And then the rest will
unfold, I was about to say.
You find this red block here.
Those are our midterms
and the final.
On those days, there's not
going to be a live class.
But I will make the final--
sorry, the exam available
for about 24 hours.
You should not spend
more than an hour,
maybe an hour and
a half on the exam.
And then submit
once you are done.
The exams are open book
in a sense that you
can look at the
textbooks, and you can
look at the course material.
But you are not supposed
to do an online search
for the solutions,
and you're also not
supposed to discuss
with your peers.
You can ask clarifying questions
on one of the Slack channels,
and we will be happy to answer
as quickly as we see them.
But again, this is an evaluation
of your own performance,
and you should submit
your own performance.
The PSETs are
different in a sense
that I encourage that you
guys build small groups
and work on them together.
Each PSET then has to
be submitted by you
as an individual, meaning
that I don't want to see
copies of PSETs of other folks.
I want your own answers
in your own words
to the questions we pose.
Very important day in January
is Martin Luther King Day,
and IAP gives us all a
little bit of a breathing
room and extra free day.
And you see that
there's going to be,
after the discussion
at the very end,
after the final, a special
lecture where I introduce
the topic of general
relativity, which is not
part of the core
content, especially
of this special
relativity class.
Textbooks-- I will not really
follow the textbooks line
by line or chapter by chapter.
But I encourage you-- and
I give you an outline--
to read them, especially
the first two ones.
The first one is by French.
The second one is by Resnick.
The first one is the
former MIT professor.
You are supposed to read
this book cover to cover,
and I give reading
assignments on this.
Resnick has a lot of good
examples and problems,
and we will focus on the first
four chapters of that book.
There is a lot of literature
out there on special relativity,
as a slew of
textbooks available.
If you have one at
hand, you can also
use that and find the
relevant chapter in there.
I give you one extra
book here, which
is nice because it is
an excellent explanation
of the mathematics involved.
If you're more
inclined to course 18,
that might be an interesting
textbook for you.
Again, there's
many, many resources
on the topic of
special relativity,
and I'll point out
a few as we go.
In addition to the textbooks,
I give you a number of papers--
for example, the paper
in which Einstein
explains or
describes the concept
of the theory of
special relativity.
And there's a few others
which I'd like you to read.
They're interesting because
they introduce the physics,
but they're also
interesting as they
have been written more than
100 years ago in a slightly
different language than
we would be using today.
And Einstein,
specifically, doesn't even
write papers the way
other people wrote papers
at the time.
He had his own style
in writing papers.
And we will see that.
So here is the reading
assignment week by week.
We start in week one by Resnick
Chapter 1, French Chapter 2.
There's two papers, the
Michelson Morley paper
and the Einstein paper
on special relativity.
And then we go on as
we go through IAP.
Your homework schedule is here.
I hand out PSET number
0 today, and I'll
explain it on the next page.
This is a PSET which allows--
I mean, this is
a PSET which will
keep you busy for the
entire month, or most of it.
The other PSETs are shorter,
and they are more pointed.
And you get the
PSET, you work on it,
and your hand in the solution.
And by the time you have
done that, the next PSET
rolls around.
I would use the PSET
load a little bit,
because I want to acknowledge
the fact that it will be harder
for you to work in teams.
I still encourage this.
You find yourself on Slack.
You find yourself
on Zoom channels.
Some of you might
have housing together.
I really encourage you guys
to discuss the physics.
There are some really
difficult concepts
which just need you to think
through and to talk through.
And the talking through best
happens with your peers.
And you will see that that will
be very beneficial, especially
when it comes to the PSET.
But here is homework number 1.
I've done this now a few
times, and I really, really
enjoy the solutions
given by the students.
So this is a creative project.
You have basically almost
all of IAP to hand it in.
And the idea is to be creative
around a topic relating
Einstein, or/and the theory
of special relativity.
The project might be a video.
It might be a poem.
It might be a musical piece,
artwork, animations, a game,
a structure--
you name it.
What I really want is that you
take something you do very well
and combine it with the
topic of this class.
I want you to take
something where
you are very familiar with where
you are feeling comfortable
and then enter this new
topic, this new topic
of special relativity.
I will rate it based on your
creativity, on the quality,
and on your effort.
And again, please hand
this in by January 22.
I really encourage you to
not wait to the last minute
to start working
on those topics,
those creative projects.
They always take a
little bit more time
than you might expect.
This class will have an
interactive component.
And we will use breakout rooms
for discussions and smaller
problems as you would be doing
in the classroom, as well.
Here is the very first one.
People who are taking
this class asynchronously,
I encourage you to stop here
and work through the problem.
And then look at the
solution afterwards,
or look at the discussion
of the solution afterwards.
So this first Gedanken
experiment, thought experiment,
is about the topic
of relativity.
And you want to
first understand what
that is, what relativity
is, before you discuss
what special relativity is.
So imagine you wake up
inside a room with no windows
and one locked door.
You checked.
You make sure that
the door is locked.
You cannot get out.
You cannot see outside.
Looking out around,
you see a table
with a number of items on it.
There's a desk lamp
plugged in and turn on.
There's a tennis ball.
There's a bunch of string.
There's a pitcher of water.
There's a cup.
There's a candle.
There's a box of matches.
And there's a music
player with headphones.
A skateboard and a wooden
stool are also in the room.
The music player has
a sign on it saying
turn it on for instructions.
So you do.
You're told that you are
in a specially designed
vibration-proof and noise-proof
train car [COUGH]---- sorry--
on a set of straight
and level train tracks.
Your task is to use one or
more of the items in the room,
perhaps in combination
with each other,
to determine whether the
train car is stationary or is
moving on the tracks.
There's a 30 minute time
limit on your test or tests.
And you cannot destroy or
you cannot modify the walls
or the floors or the
ceiling of the car.
That is not permitted.
So the question to you is, can
you think of some creative way
to use the items that might
indicate whether or not
you are moving.
Think about this and discuss
in your breakout rooms--
that is, for the
live session here.
Again, I want to encourage
you to stop and to think
about a solution.
Can you think about a creative
way to work with this?
The typical time is
about 10 minutes.
You might think about it.
You might want to
take some notes.
All right, the answer is
you cannot figure it out.
Every reference frame
by itself is inert.
You cannot figure out whether
or not you are in a moving
or in a stationary
reference frame.
And as long as you
cannot feel vibrations,
or you hear the sound, or
you have some other internal,
external indication, you will
not be able to figure out
whether or not the room
is moving with a constant
velocity.
You will be able to feel
or measure accelerations.
And so now you could
argue that since the train
track is on Earth, and
the Earth is actually--
since you are on Earth,
and if you're moving,
you would be able to feel
the rotation of the Earth,
there might be a way
to figure this out.
But that will be
very, very hard to do.
So the answer is you cannot.
You cannot distinguish one
reference frame from another.
You don't know what an
absolute velocity is.
So another way we will
interact in this class
is through concept questions.
So here, concept
questions are meant
to give you a little
bit of a checkpoint
to encourage you to think
about what I just explained
in a video or in the
class and to stimulate
some sort of discussion.
Sometimes you will use contact
questions in breakout rooms
for the discussion
part sometimes
you just use Zoom features
in order to figure out
what the answer is.
But besides the technology,
those concept questions
are really for you to figure
out whether or not you just
understand the concept.
So again, I encourage
you to pause the video
to think about the
concept question
and then move on
with the answer.
Here's an example.
A new Star Wars
movie came out, 2019.
And I ask you to pick the answer
closest to your level of Star
Wars expertise.
I saw the movie, and I consider
myself a Star Wars fan.
I saw the new movie, but I do
not know much about Star Wars.
I heard about Star Wars, but
I didn't see the movie yet.
Always liked Star Trek better.
What?
Star Wars?
OK, so very straightforward--
here I would give you
an option--
1, 2, 3, or 4.
You collect the answers,
and we get some feedback.
This is obviously-- there's
no right answer here.
There can be concept
questions where there
is a right and a wrong answer.
And again, for you,
this is supposed
to give you feedback on how
well you understood the concept.
All right, before we
close this first video,
I want to introduce
players, Alice and Bob.
We will have, often,
discussions of reference frames.
Typically Alice or Bob are
in one reference frame.
And then the other person is
in the other reference frame.
I want you to think about
those Star Trek figures.
We will use spacecrafts.
We will use light--
so phasers or light pistols--
in order to demonstrate the
impact of special relativity
and understand the concepts.